in the last video we looked at three
different examples really is a bit of a
review of some of our factoring
techniques and also to appreciate when
we might want to apply them and we saw
in the first example that it was just a
a process of recognizing a common factor
and once we factored that out we were
done in the second example there was a
common factor four but then after that
we used you could say our most basic
factoring technique or one of our more
basic factoring techniques where we say
okay what two numbers add up to this
middle to the first degree coefficient
and then their product is the constant
and we were able to factor the
expression and then in the third example
we once again started off by factoring
out a common a common value which in
this case was 3 and we could have done
it the same way we did the second one or
we could have immediately recognized
that this is a perfect square polynomial
but either way we were able to factor
the expression let's keep going to see
if we can
tackle some other types of polynomials
that might require some other techniques
so let's say we have
the expression 7x squared minus 63. like
always pause this video and see if you
can factor that
all right well i've intentionally
designed all of these so that you can
check whether there's a common factor
across the terms and here they're all
divisible by seven so if you factor out
a 7 you're going to get 7 times x
squared minus 9.
now you might immediately recognize this
as a difference of squares you have x
squared minus
this right over here is 3 squared
minus 3 squared
and so if the term difference of squares
or how to factor them is completely
foreign to you i encourage you to watch
the dif the videos on factoring
difference of squares or do a search on
khan academy for difference of squares
but you will see when you have a
difference of squares like this it can
be factored as
7 this is just a 7 out front and then
this part right over here
do a different color this part right
over here can be written as
x plus 3
times x
minus 3. it is x squared
minus 3
minus 3 squared
now one thing to appreciate this really
isn't a different technique than the one
that we saw in the previous video if we
just focused on x squared
minus 9 you could view this as x squared
plus 0 x
minus 9. in that case you'd say ok what
two numbers get me a product of negative
nine and add up to zero
well if i need to get a product of
negative nine that must that means that
they must be different signs a positive
and a negative otherwise they're the
same sign you'd get a positive here so
they're different signs and nine only
has three factors one
so you could either have
one and nine or you could there's only
two combinations here you can either
have one or nine and three and three
and if you make one negative or nine
negative
that's not going to add up to zero but
if you make one of these threes negative
that does add up to zero so you say okay
well my two numbers are going to be
negative three and three and so it's
going to be x minus three times x plus
three and once again i'm just focusing
on what was inside the parentheses right
over here you would put that 7 out front
if we were doing this exact same
expression but if you recognize it as a
difference of squares it might happen
for you a little bit faster
let's do one more example
so let's say that i have
two x squared plus seven x
plus
three
so in general when my coefficient on the
second degree term here is not a one i
try to see if is there a common factor
here
but 7 isn't divisible by 2 and neither
is 3. so i can't use the techniques that
i used in the last few videos or even
over here where i say oh there's there's
a common factor and get a leading
coefficient of 1. so if you see a
situation like that it's a clue that
factoring by grouping might apply here
and factoring by grouping in on some
level everything that we've just done
now you can view special cases of
factoring by grouping but factoring by
grouping you say okay
can i think of two numbers
that add up to this coefficient so a
plus b
is equal to 7
and a times b
instead of just saying it needs to equal
to 3
it actually needs to be equal to 3 times
this 3 times the leading coefficient the
coefficient on the x squared term so it
needs to be equal to 3 times 2. if you
think about it we've always been doing
that but you the other examples we gave
the leading coefficient was a one so
whenever you took the constant term and
multiplied it by one you're saying oh
well a times b needs to be equal to that
constant term but if we want to talk
about it more generally it should be a
times b should be the constant term
times the leading coefficient and in the
introduction to factoring by grouping we
explain why that works you should never
just accept this as some magic formula
it makes sense for a very good
mathematical reason but once you accept
that then it's useful to be able to
apply the technique
so can we think of two numbers that add
up to 7 and whose product
is equal to 6 and they're going to have
to be the same sign since this is a
positive value
and they're going to be positive because
they're adding they're the same side as
they're adding up to a positive value
they're both going to be positive
well let's see 1 and 6 seems to work 1
plus 6 is 7 1 times 6 is 6. so in
factoring by grouping we rewrite our
expression where we break this up
between the a and the b so i can rewrite
this as 2 x squared plus 6 x plus i
could write 1x actually let me just do
that plus
1x plus 3. and as you can see
the 7x let me just a different color the
7x has been broken up into the 6x and 1x
so that whole exercise i just did is to
see how we can break up this first
degree term right over here but then
what's useful about this
is now we can essentially apply the just
we can undistribute the we can do the
reverse of the distributive property
twice
so for
these first two terms
just in a different color than i just
use
these first two terms
you see a common factor 2x squared and
6x they're both divisible by 2x so let's
factor out a 2x out of those first two
terms so if you do that
2x squared divided by 2x you're just
going to have an x left over and 6x
divided by 2x you're just going to have
a 3.
and then you have plus
and then over here this is a special
situation where
x plus 3 there is no common factor
between x and 3 so we'll just rewrite
that x plus 3.
but when i put a parenthesis on it which
is equivalent to writing it without a
parenthesis you might see something else
well i can un-distribute or i can factor
out an x plus 3.
so what happens if i do that i'm going
to get an x plus 3
and then i'm going to have left over in
this term
if i factored out an x plus 3 i'm just
going to have a 2x left over
2x
and then this term if i factor out an x
plus 3 well i'm just going to have a 1
left over plus
1. let me do that same color
having trouble switching colors today 2x
plus 1. and we are done so as i said
these are all various techniques on some
level factoring by grouping is sometimes
viewed as the hardest one but i'll say
hard in parentheses because everything
we did is just a variation really a
special case of factoring by grouping
and as you can see it's all about well
two numbers that add up to that middle
coefficient that on the first degree
term when it's written in standard form
and their product is equal to the
product of the constant
and the leading coefficient and if you
do that you break it up it works out
quite nicely where you keep factoring
out terms and this one in some levels
was a little bit more subtle because you
have to recognize that this x plus 3 has
a 1 coefficient out there on there
implicitly 1 times x plus 3 is the same
thing as x plus 3. and then see that you
can factor out an x plus 3 out of both
of these terms and then once you do that
you're going to be left with a 2x plus
1. but all of these if you really feel
comfortable with this arsenal of
techniques you're going to be pretty
you're going to do pretty well
and frankly if none of these work well
you might already be familiar with the
quadratic formula or you might be soon
to learn it but that's when the
quadratic formula might be effective
if none of these techniques work